hi we're gonna get started I'm a Shannon
McWeeny I'm the division head for
bioinformatics and computational biology
normally our seminars introduced by dr.
Hirsch our department chair
I believe he's luckily on vacation right
now so enjoying some time off so I'm
happy to do this um we like to introduce
the students and we asked them to write
a bio and I usually try to wing it but I
actually really like what Vincent wrote
so I'm going to read it because um it's
pretty awesome so Vincent earned a mrs.
Vincent Cousteau who's speaking today
he's also defending this is our public
defense of his thesis Vincent earned a
Bachelor of Science in electrical
engineering from the University of
Southern California after a short stint
at Aerospace Corporation and a long
travel break here in to master of
science at Columbia also an electrical
engineering this led him to decide
finally not to become after all that
education and electrical engineer
instead he learned carpentry this is the
part I love it's why I didn't want to
wing this you didn't want me to wing
this and worked in residential
remodeling for seven years a radio lab
which is one of my favorite programs
episode on genetic engineering
engineering inspired a new fascination
with biology and after two years were
prereqs at PCC Vinson came to the
bioinformatics program here at OHSU his
current research is on data processing
and analysis for the study of human
micro biomes
he's also interning and this is really
wonderful at the Oregon State Public
Health lab where we have a joint
internship program where he works on a
whole genome sequence analysis of
pathogenic bacteria so it is my pleasure
to introduce him I want to make a couple
of comments
we are live-streaming this and so there
may be questions that I'll be reading we
will be asking why am I asking so many
questions it's because I'm actually
monitoring from the web we sometimes get
questions that way and at the end
because we're recording we'll need to
use the microphone correct or we're
using yes great Thank You Lynne so just
raise your hand I'll bring the mic so
that way it's actually captured so that
everyone can hear it and people who
watch the recording later can hear it
Vincent it's all you thank you
is that better okay I can tell well it's
loaded okay um okay so as I was saying
micro biomes are found all over and
inside the human body and so as you can
see here they're they're found in our
guts on our skin in our mouths vaginas
urinary tract etc etc it seems like just
about everywhere researchers look we're
finding micro microbial communities
living there so why do we care well one
of the big motivations for studying
micro biomes is that we found that they
have a pretty big impact on our health
so a lot of studies have found that
changes in what's considered the normal
or healthy composition of the microbiome
is associated with a wide range of
diseases and I'm showing some of these
here they range from things like crohn's
disease to acne to pancreatic cancer
even microbial communities also are
known to play a role in regulating the
immune system so microbiome community
profiles have great potential to be used
for diagnosis and prognosis of diseases
and they can also possibly predict
response to treatments and if you guys
listen to NPR you might have heard a
story a little while ago about a study
that showed that microbiome composition
predicted people's response some cancer
patients response to chemotherapy so in
contrast to the sites that I just showed
you on the last slide there are some
sites that are home to a low a low
biomass microbiome and that just means
that there's a lower density of microbes
there so some examples I'm showing you
here are the the urinary tract and the
mucosae of the lungs but just like with
those other high biomass sites there are
also a number of diseases that have been
found associated with dysbiosis of the
microbial communities at these sites but
because of the relative scarcity of
microbes in sites like these they
present some special challenges to
studying and researching them and just
sort of a hint of these challenges
both of these sites were long believed
to be sterile because we couldn't grow
any of the microbes there they were so
sparse so we didn't think there was
anything to study so currently the most
popular or the most common technique for
studying microbial communities is to
sequence what's called the the 16s
ribosomal RNA gene one reason for this
choice is that the 16s gene is found in
all prokaryotes so that's bacteria
mainly but it's not found in eukaryotes
like humans and animals so if you target
the 16s and sequenced that then you only
sequence the prokaryotic organisms but
not the human host for example so the
other reason for targeting 16s is the
somewhat unique evolution and so the
graph here is showing the relative
conservation along the length of the the
16s gene to the showing the length of
different regions different reasons the
16s gene here and the the Peaks here
that are highlighted by pink bars these
are the most highly conserved regions of
the gene that are found in nearly all
prokaryotic organisms the same sequence
and then the valleys that are labeled
with these these are called hyper
variable regions and they vary so much
between organisms that they act like a
barcode that can kind of identify the
organism that they came from and so if
you target a certain region the 16s gene
that includes a hyper variable region
then you can get an idea of like a
census of the the prokaryotic organisms
that are in your sample this is just a
high-level work flow for a 16s
sequencing experiment we call them
amplicons
when we're targeting a specific region
and especially you just want to
highlight the middle step here because
16s sequencing requires that you do
several cycles of a polymerase chain
reaction or PCR which just makes a bunch
of copies of the specific part of the
gene that you're trying to sequence and
the importance of this will become clear
a little bit later I'll come back and
talk about the PCR cycles in this
amplification of the gene
first this is a hypothetical example of
the kind of data that you might get when
you do a 16s sequencing experiment and
you see it at the beginnings and the
ends of all of these sequences in grade
have the exact same primer sequences so
this is what you use to target the gene
and all the organisms because it's
essentially the same but then they all
have regions that bury in between and
they're color-coded by by by which one's
match each other and so this region
gives you information about what
organism that sequence came from and
then the abundance of each of the color
coded sequences here gives you an idea
of the abundance of the organism in the
sample it's somewhat correlated the goal
of a 16s experiment is to give a
community profile sort of like this that
identifies what organisms are present as
well as their their relative abundances
of prevalence in the sample and of
course we want this the census or
profile to be as accurate as possible so
the simplest way to go about getting a
profile might be to just identify all
the unique sequences in your sample and
then count up the number of each and
that would give you an idea of the
number of organisms and their abundance
and then you could map them to a
database of known 16s gene sequences to
get taxonomic labels and while this this
might have worked well in the early days
of sequencing for example Sanger
sequencing which was relatively low
throughput with modern high-throughput
sequencing technologies this turns out
to be a pretty lousy strategy because
the the 16s reads sequences that come
out of the sequencer have a lot of noise
in them and so what this thus ends up
meaning is that if you try to do this
strategy with a modern sequencing
experiment you might think your sample
has thousands or even tens of thousands
of of distinct organisms and it might
actually only have a couple dozen okay
so what do I mean by noise when I use
noise here I just mean a sequence that's
found in your read data set
is not found it doesn't come from the
biological sample it doesn't match
what's in the biological sample so
there's two different types of noise
that are found in the data
the first is biological noise and this
means this refers to DNA contaminant so
it's it's biological DNA but it's not in
the community that you're that you're
studying and this can cap in as a result
of contamination during sample
collection or laboratory processing
there there are a number of sources in
the lab that can possibly contaminate
the sample and it's very difficult to
practice a perfectly aseptic technique
the other type of noise is technical
noise one source is called is from PCR
that polymerase chain reaction it can
happen where two biological sequences
will spontaneously fuse in the middle to
make a hybrid sequence that doesn't
represent anything biological that's
called a chimera the other kind of
technical noise that I'm more focused on
here particularly with the Illumina
sequencing platform that's the
predominant sequencing technology today
and the most common type of sequencer
error in Illumina is when one nucleotide
is misread and reported as a different
one this is called a substitution error
and so for my thesis project I'm looking
at different ways of correctly inferring
the community composition when there's
noisy data because of these different
kinds of sources okay so how do
researchers deal with this well for
about a decade or so the most popular
strategy has been to cluster the reed
sequences into operational taxonomic
units or ot use for short and this uses
a simple similarity threshold to cluster
the reads and so I'm gonna illustrate
how this works with a little
demonstration so I have a toy microbiome
sample with these five different colored
organisms and the distance between the
dots represents the the difference
between their 16s gene sequences and the
size of the dot is correlating to the
abundance or the prevalence of that
organism so if I took the sample and did
a 16s sequencing experiment I'm going to
get
some noisy data that might look like
this so most of the read sequences are
going to be the correct ones that are
the darker shaded dots but then some of
them are going to have errors and that's
shown by the lighter shaded dots at the
same color so they're derived from the
darker shade but they they have some
sequencing errors and they're kind of
distributed around the biological
sequences of the template that generated
them and so the way that ODU clustering
accounts for this is just by using a
fixed similarity threshold that makes
like a radius like this and the letter T
is showing you the length of the radius
but I think from this example which of
course I designed specially to show you
this you can see that there are some
problems with OTU clustering first of
all it can't resolve fine
fine variation so if to see if two
organisms have very similar 16s
sequences such as the blue and the
purple then ot use may cluster them as
one and infer only a single organism but
then the other problem is that they can
especially with high-throughput
sequencing there can be sequence or
noise that falls outside the threshold
so it's there's these light green dots
that didn't get clustered with the dark
green organism that that generated them
and so they can generate false positives
like this one that doesn't correspond to
anything real so of course there must be
an alternative and one that's reversed
in the last couple of years is to
replace the fixed distance threshold
with an explicit model of the sequence
or error and these error modeling
methods is I'm going to call them take
into account not only the distance
between sequences or the difference
between them but also the abundance of
their reads in the data so to illustrate
with multiple dimensions both the the
distance between and the abundance and
use the different representations so
instead of dots I'm gonna represent a
sequence by a bar here the Hamming
distance on the x-axis Hamming distance
is just a measure of how similar or help
far apart sequences are its how many
positions are different between them and
then the height of the bar is showing
you it's a bun
and so this dark orange bar let's say
it's a single organism right now my
sample and if I did an experiment I'm
sorry first of all this the dotted grey
line is a hypothetical error model and
so what the model shows is that I expect
the correct sequence to have the highest
frequency so that's where the peak of
the error model is centered over the the
true sequence but then the more errors I
have so the farther away on the x-axis
the less frequent I expect those errors
to be a singular may be relatively
frequent but multiple errors is going to
be rare okay so what if I use this to to
cluster that same toy sample well first
I need to transform it from dots to bars
and then if I did a sequencing
experiment I'll get some noisy data and
you see the errors in the gray bars
there and then if I apply the error
model to this data set this is what I
might get and you can see that the error
model that I the hypothetical air model
resolves all five of the organisms in
the sample because each of the true
organisms is too abundant to to fit
under a be consistent with the error
model of any of the others and so it
does very well in this at least in this
example um and then for contrast OTU
methods we've just been these sequences
like this it doesn't consider the height
it's only a fixed width of the distance
between them and there's one more
sequence inference algorithm that I
considered for this project and this
approach looks at the the amount of the
total amount of variation which is also
called entropy of at individual sequence
positions in a set of reads and so by a
sequence position I mean a column in the
aligned set of reads so starting with
the full data set on the left all in one
cluster if the entropy of a certain
position or the variation is above a
certain threshold then the algorithm
would split that cluster to make the
entropy zero in the new cluster so you
see all the sequences that had a's when
if the
after one and all the sequences that had
geez there went into cluster two and
then this this continues so this column
maybe has some variation but there's
only one difference there it doesn't get
above the entropy threshold so we leave
it alone but then there's another one
with with higher entropy several
differences and so it gets split and
once the entropy of all positions in the
clusters is below the threshold then
your clustering is complete so this is
the entropy based algorithm so now that
you have an overview of the algorithms
I'll be comparing I'm going to move on
to talk more about the specific methods
that I'm that I'm benchmarking here and
my first aim which is to look at the how
well they perform on high microbial
biomass samples so this kind of gives a
baseline of their performance before I
move on to the second aim which is
looking at how things change when we
have decreasing microbial biomass of the
sample okay so these are the the six
different community inference methods
that I'm comparing there are two OTU
based methods three error modeling
methods and a single entropy based
method and I'm going to briefly discuss
my choice of each one of these so first
for OTU methods there are more than a
dozen published OTU clustering methods
because they've been so popular for so
long and some of them have multiple
versions so first of all eliminate my my
choice to only methods that don't rely
on a reference database for making their
cluster seeds first of all the
references are always changing and being
updated so it's kind of a moving target
but also they introduce bias from the
beginning based on which reference you
choose also the other methods don't use
reference databases so this allows more
of an apples-to-apples comparison here I
chose the first one you clust because
it's been the default method in a very
popular 16s analysis pipeline called
chyme and so time has been cited in a
lot of papers so you classed has been
sort of a
de facto standard in the field for a
while even though I think in some cases
people don't realize it because it's
just the default method and chime I
didn't expect to you class to perform
very well but because it's been used a
lot and cited its it provides kind of a
baseline for comparison and how much
better we might be able to do you parse
the other one is a very similar
algorithm to you quest but it's
different in that it performs an
additional quality filtering step before
it makes the reads so it gets rid of a
lot of the lower quality data before it
starts making the clusters and you parse
in a previous benchmarking study was
shown to reduce the number of false
positives relative to most other OTU
methods now for the three error modeling
methods I chose all three of these
because they're the only three
standalone error model methods that have
been published so far and I think they
all have the potential to improve on the
OTU approach as my demonstration
probably suggested to give you a brief
idea of the the differences between them
there's two of them that use an a priori
model so the model is fixed before it
sees the data step is not based on a
specific data set it's just a sort of
average estimate of the error and then
there's one data - that does look at the
data set and sort of adjust its error
model based on the data that it let you
give it and then among the two methods
that using a priority model you noise
uses a smooth per parametric function
that looks a lot like the hypothetical
error model I showed you earlier and
dubler uses a piecewise error model that
specifies the expected frequency of
errors at each hamming distance as you
get further away from the template and
finally I chose meed because it's the
only published example of an entropy
based method and it's also been shown to
have better sensitivity than otu methods
and so it kind of gives a you know an
alternative to otu and error modeling
methods so at least we have three and
then meed besides what i already
described about entropy based methods
has this
after cluster formation it filters
attempts to filter out noise by removing
clusters that have low abundance
relative to the dataset and by default
anything any cluster with less than
point zero two percent of the reads of
the full dataset will get thrown away
because it's considered to be just noise
of some sort
alright and then to benchmark these six
methods I needed some some datasets
where sort of knew ahead of time what
the community composition was and so for
this I use what are called mock
communities and these are biological
samples that are prepared by mixing
isolated cultures of organisms and sort
of fixed proportions so I know what I'm
putting in I know what to expect in the
community composition and for the first
a my chose for the high microbial
biomass I chose three publicly available
mock community datasets and one new
dataset that was generated here at OHSU
by mark as Chris lab so I've nicknamed
the the public datasets by their first
authors and the Kazakh dataset has 21
different bacterial strains and they all
have equal starting proportions of DNA
the Schirmer and the mone datasets have
the same 57 strains in them but the
Schirmer has equal proportions of DNA
whereas them what it uses varying
proportions or uneven proportions and
then the new data set called Zemo is
from the cyma by omics microbial
standard and it has eight strains with
equal proportions of G of DNA so this is
a schematic of my of my data processing
pipeline the first phase in blue is
where I filter out the very low quality
data and trim the ends of the reads that
are typically unreliable and then the
second phase is the the meet where I do
the community inference with one of the
six methods and the third stage is where
I analyze the results and and try to
make distinctions between them so the
first in the third stage with some minor
exceptions stay the same for each of the
six methods
and of course I need to have a way of
evaluating results so so starting with
the the complete set of inferred
sequences from each method I classified
the sequences according to a scheme that
I'll show you here
first of all if a in first sequence
perfectly match the known sequence of
one of the community community members
then I called it a reference and then so
the more references I detect relative to
what I'm expecting the better method
sensitivity so this is a measure of
sensitivity it's one to ten nucleotides
different from a known reference
sequence I called it ref noisy so the
idea here is that this is these are most
likely sequences that are the result of
sequence or error technical error in
sequencing the reference sequences that
were Mis inferred as distinct organisms
so any any sequences that we're
remaining I compared to the NT database
from NCBI and this is sort of like a
giant catalog of known DNA sequences and
any any remaining sequences that
perfectly match an NT sequence I called
a contaminant the idea is that these are
most likely true biological contaminants
if they match a known DNA sequence that
I wasn't expecting anything that is one
to ten nucleotides off from a
contaminant sequence I called
contaminoids e again the assumption is
this is that this is coming from a
sequence or error in trying to sequence
these biological contaminants and
finally anything that's left over is
just other it's none of the above and I
also want to point out that ref noisy's
in particular and contaminoids e to an
extent are measuring the specificity of
of an inference method because I want
you know ideally they'll have very few
of these because these are from
technical noise and I want them to
distinguish the technical noise is not a
real organism so if there's a bunch of
these that's not good that means low
specificity
all right now without further ado I'll
show you how each of these methods
performed on the high microbial biomass
MOC communities okay so first of all I
think it's pretty interesting just to
look at the total number of sequences
inferred so each row in these tables is
corresponding to one of the six methods
and each column is one of the four data
sets and they're the rows are
color-coded by the type of algorithm
also so one thing that stands out for me
is that you quest is always inferring
the highest number of sequences among
all methods and sometimes by an order of
magnitude you parse is tending to be on
the high side as well the three error
model methods down here are generally
reporting lower numbers of sequences and
the kind of in the same ballpark as the
expected number the expected community
sequences are on the bottom here in bold
so their model methods would think
they're closer to what I expect at least
deep blur is is always reporting the
least number of sequences and data too
is on the high side for the error model
methods so to get more insight into
these total numbers you can look at the
different that the classification scheme
that I applied so starting with the
reference sequences we find that even
though the OTU methods reported high
numbers of overall overall they have
relatively poor sensitivity because
they're always detecting the fewest
number of community sequences or
references and the error model methods
are typically detecting the most
reference sequences the OCU methods are
especially bad on these more diverse
data sets where they have quite a bit
fewer reference detections and the
others among the hermanos is it looks
like deep blur is maybe a little less
sensitive than the new noise and data -
especially right here you see that and
no method is perfect on the demo date
data so it's possible that some
sequences were so rare in that data set
that they they may have been removed by
by the quality filtering step or
just not shown up in the data set at all
right next to ref noisy category it also
shows some big differences between the
methods here we find the only you clust
and meed have notably large numbers of
sequences in again these are supposed
false positives so this captures
sequences that have errors that were
incorrectly inferred as distinct
organisms and this suggests that you
cluster nemi dr not dealing with the
sequence or noise very well but you
parse and all the error model methods
don't seem to be affected by this
sequencer noise much at all okay in the
contaminant category was was supposed to
represent biological noise or
contaminating DNA and you see that
pretty much all methods report at least
some contaminants so I'm concluding that
there's there is some biological noise
present in each of these samples you can
see again that the otu methods are
reporting relatively high numbers that
I've highlighted here and meed is
reporting the fewest so given that we've
already seen that the OTU methods were
less sensitive and in case of you class
less specific I don't with the reference
sequences I don't take this as meaning
that these are more sensitive now I
think this actually shows poor
specificity on the part of the otu
methods or they're finding false
positives in the contaminant category
here Emmie DS low very low numbers here
are mostly explained by its noise
abundance filter so the contaminants are
at a low enough abundance they didn't
pass the threshold for MU DS noise
filter and they just got thrown away
among the error model methods to the
data to is reporting the most so that
either means that data too is more
sensitive than the other two or it could
be less specific and these might also be
some false positives but but I don't
think there's enough evidence to decide
either way right now and then finally
there's the other category that shows
some difference it mostly just so it
shows that you clust in you parse
apparently are these are probably false
positives campus is totally sure but
they're the only ones that have notable
numbers here and so it's further
evidence that they are overestimating
the sample diversity I think okay so far
I've just been looking at the number of
unique sequences that are inferred by
each method but if we look at abundance
or the the number of reads that are
supporting the sequences in each
category we get a pretty different
picture so here I'm showing the total
relative abundances of sequences in each
of the five classification categories so
there's a different plot for each of the
four data sets and then each of these
bars is one of the six methods that you
see on the x-axis so here we see that
that the vast majority of reads are
supporting the blue reference category
the plots look pretty boring because
it's all reference and that's the target
community so the only non reference
contributions of note are these light
blue ref noisy's the biggest one for MeV
and a little less for you noise and dota
2 and then we also see that for the
Schirmer and demoting datasets it looks
like all methods are inferring a small
but notable proportion of contaminant
sequences that's the red all right so I
think we can make some broad conclusions
from this the first aim the OTU methods
and meed all showed either poor
sensitivity or poor specificity or both
and all three of the error modeling
methods had pretty good sensitivity and
specificity in all the data sets so
looks like the error modeling methods
are kind of the clear winners here also
there were a few contaminant sequences
detected in each of the data sets but
their overall abundances was very small
and so they have a relatively low impact
on community in France so that brings me
to my second aim which was to evaluate
sequence inference when the microbial
biomass of a sample is
creasing and getting small okay so how
with low biomass change the overall
picture that's the question
so as we just saw with high biomass
samples there is some noise from
bacterial contaminants but as I'm
illustrating the level of contamination
is pretty small relative to the actual
community sequences and the sample
sequences in blue dominate the the read
data set but one thing you have to
realize is that even if the community
biomass gets smaller the the
contaminating DNA is not going to get
smaller in the same way because it's
coming from an outside source it doesn't
come from the community sample so when I
go to amplify the 16s Gene's in PCR like
I mentioned earlier if there's less
community DNA then the contaminant is
going to make up the contaminant DNA is
going to make up a larger proportion of
the total sample and now it's more
likely to get amplified in PCR along
with the community gene sequences and so
if you get a very low biomass community
you might end up with a picture more
like this where the contaminants get
amplified and sequenced enough that they
actually make up a large proportion of
the overall sample and the data set that
you're sequencing so kind of looking for
for two different things in the second
aim how is community inference impacted
by this this scenario how much of an
impact does contamination have and also
how do the different methods handle this
situation and what does their
performance look like when we have low
low biomass so to mimic samples are
different starting biomass we created a
dilution series again this was in in
mark a Swiss lab here on campus from
that same Zemo MOC community that was
used in in aim one so a total of nine
samples were generated by diluting each
successive sample to one third the
relative dilution relative to the
previous sample until that gives you
dilution series with relative dilutions
that are shown in this table here so the
the DNA concentration is a standing for
for but microbial biomass of the
community and then these nine samples
were sequenced on an Illumina sequencer
to get the raw data in this undiluted
sample here it's the same one that I
used in the high biomass first part of
the project and the procedure for the
second aim is essentially the same as
for the first except now instead of
benchmarking methods on different
datasets I'm using the same mock
community but now different solutions
and of course I'm using the same
classification scheme to evaluate the
results so with that let's see what I
found on the dilution series
benchmarking and I'll go mostly go
through the results one category at a
time at least the interesting ones but
instead of showing you tables I think
it's easier to see visually like this so
now along the x-axis you have the
relative dilution so this is undiluted
and this is the most dilute or least
concentrated sample and the y-axis is
showing the number of sequences inferred
by a method methods are color-coded in
here with it and also they're color
coded by algorithm so ODU's are blue
orange for meb and error models in green
so starting again these are the total
numbers of sequences inferred and the
trends I think we see pretty obviously
is that for a given method the sequence
the number of sequences inferred tends
to increase as dilution increases and
hopefully that makes sense given my
discussion of what happens with PCR
amplification and at lower deletions we
see just like with high biomass view
clusters inferring the most sequences
but then when we get to higher deletions
over here it's no longer the otu methods
with it some of the error modeling
methods and meed
gets to the highest of all there and it
looks like the sequence totals drop off
a lot at the end of the dilution series
the main explanation for this I think is
that those samples had a much smaller
sequencing depth so they just generated
a lot fewer reads so
they're around you know 50,000 reads
compared to a hundred to two hundred
thousand reads or more from us together
samples so if this were corrected for
the number of reads then this trend
would pretty much continue across the
dilution series all right okay this is
not a test of the emergency broadcast
system this is actually showing the
number of reference sequences and what
happened here is that all the methods
recovered all of the the community
sequences at each dilution so it's kind
of disappointing because I thought that
at least some of the methods would have
imperfect recall over at the hired
Aleutians but my conclusion is not that
they all had perfect sensitivity it's
just that this particular mock community
didn't challenge the sensitivity of any
of any of the methods I'm well enough
but if we move on to the ref noisy
sequences there are some interesting
differences just like with what we saw
with the high biomass samples we see
that you clust and meed are are not
doing a very good job of recognizing
sequence or error as noise but the other
four methods that have very low totals
across of ref noses across the dilution
series they don't seem to be affected
pretty much like we saw before on a high
biomass but none of this explains why
the sequences are increasing across the
dilution series until we look at the
contaminant category and so here we see
what's really driving the increase in
total sequences inferred because there's
a pretty dramatic increase especially
from the 1/3 to the 1/9 dilution and
then continuing on and you'll see that
the the y-axis is going above 300 so
it's a lot of purported contaminants
when the concentration is dropping so to
make it easier what see to see what's
going on with each method applauding
trend lines for each of them separately
there are six six plots for the six
methods contaminant counts are in orange
and contaminoids ease i also included in
purple here so some important
differences show up
first of all for the three error model
methods that are on the bottom you see
an almost linear increase in the number
of sequences inferred as the
concentration decreases and going back
to my discussion of what happens when
when biomass gets low and the
contamination is increasingly amplified
then I think this linear increase in
sequence is detected is what we should
expect and so I think it's evidence that
the error model error model methods are
doing a reasonably accurate job of
detecting that biological noise by
contrast the OTU methods these first two
they show an initial jump in the number
of sequences detected but then it kind
of levels off in plateaus and they stop
responding to changes in the sample
dilution and so this to me I mean I
think this shows a lack of accuracy it's
a they're not super sensitive right here
I think this is more lack of specificity
and false positives and then just not
responding to dilution is more evidence
of poor accuracy by the otu methods and
then meed is kind of all by itself at
first it doesn't report any contaminant
and then it jumps up to show the highest
number of all at the beginning the the
abundance filter is taking out the rare
contaminants and then when when they get
more and more abundant they get over the
filter but because it spikes up so high
I think this is this is more evidence
that meed
has poor specificity I think there's
some some false positives that are
inflating this number which is also what
we saw with the ref noisy sequences so
again those are those are the the main
results for the sequence counts but I
also want to show you what's going on at
the reed level so there's not a whole
lot of difference between the six
methods here so you can kind of just pay
attention to one of them the most
striking thing is that as the
concentration decreases the contaminant
reeds are making up an ever-increasing
proportion of the total sample so not
only we see that the number of
contaminant sequences increase but also
their overall abundance in the sample
increasing and they're actually really
dominating the sample at the lower
concentrations all right finally we can
get a different kind of information if
we look at the distributions of the
abundances of the sequences at each
dilution so I'm showing here log
transformed abundance distribution so
note the y-axis it's in powers of 10 so
a small jump actually represents a big
difference and there's just two groups
that I'm plotting here the reference
abundances in blue abundance
distributions and the contaminant
abundance distributions in orange and I
only planted two methods because I don't
have room on one slide for all six but
but also you have to believe me that the
the trend we see for dubler
is pretty similar to what we saw for
what I saw for most of the methods so
it's it's a representative and the plot
gives you a sense of how well the
sequence inference can separate the
target community from sources of
biological noise um what I found for
dubler and most of the methods is that
as concentration decreases from left to
right the reference signal distribution
in blue is kind of steadily declining
and on the other hand the abundance of
the contaminant sequences on average is
rising as we go to lower concentrations
until they go from being pretty well
separated to hopelessly overlaps over
here so this shows that for low
microbial biomass samples we can't hope
to separate target community from from
biological noise by using just a
threshold filter anywhere we draw a
horizontal line here is either going to
cut out some of the reference sequences
or include a bunch of the contaminating
sequences which is what we want to avoid
and then meed
is the exception to this trend you can
see that the contaminants are relatively
flat again this is probably mostly due
to its abundance filter which is cutting
out all of the low abundance sequences
at the bottom and flattening out that
trend so
but to me the most interesting thing
maybe from this trend is that it kind of
suggests a possible strategy for
identifying and removing contamination
and the idea goes like this if you
include a dilution series as a positive
control with your study samples in a 16s
sequencing experiment then you could
look for sequences in the dilution
series that that have a positive
correlation with dilution and you could
label these sequences as contaminants so
you see the the orange highlighted ones
have rising abundances in the dilution
series and then you can remove any of
those sequences you get you get a set of
a contaminants and then any of those
sequences that show up in your study
samples that are labeled as contaminants
you can just get rid of them so this is
not a totally original idea there is a
version of this that's been implemented
by another group but with there's
there's certainly a lot of room for
research here and new ideas or
implementations all right so I think we
can make some general conclusions from
the overall study first of all a recap
of the high biomass we found that you
cluster you parson meed all suffered
from either poor sensitivity for
specificity or both so probably less
recommended to use these whereas the
error model methods had reasonably good
sensitivity and specificity also we saw
that contamination was present but at a
pretty small abundance and so maybe not
a big impact on community inference but
with the the second aim for the
decreasing biomass contamination looked
like it can have a very large impact on
community inference overall there are
many more contaminant sequences that
show up and they have they tend to have
much higher abundances and and make up a
large portion of the sample we also saw
that no method on its own can can simply
tell the difference between reference
sequences and and our community
sequences and contaminants so so I'm
more interested in which ones are
accurately identifying the contaminating
sequences which look like it was the
error
methods because they showed the best
correlation with concentration both in
terms of the numbers of sequences that I
am that they inferred but also the
abundances which which all methods did
pretty good with but one thing to note
is that I couldn't really make much
distinction between the free error
modeling methods so I think further
benchmarking research with more data is
needed to kind of determine which of
those might be the best in a situation
and finally more research overall is
needed in in the area of contamination
identification especially for low
biomass 16s sequencing experiments
because they could it really has a large
impact and for the most part it's I
don't think it's being it's not being
addressed adequately by the current
research and I just want to finally
point out a couple of limitations for
this study some caveats first of all the
MOC community structure you saw with
that ugly plot of the reference
sequences that this the composition of
this MOC community design of MOC
community is not necessarily
representative of a biological sample
it's only 8 sequences and typically you
would have more different organisms and
they also wouldn't have the same
relative proportions to each other
there'd be a wide range of abundances
also the classification scheme that I
used the the definitions are inexact so
inevitably there will be some overlap
between the different categories for
example ref noise and contaminants might
be might get mixed up a little bit but I
think overall the results that I saw
pretty well supported the definitions
that I used and made useful distinctions
between the methods and finally I only
had one dilution series so especially
for distinguishing between error
modeling methods having different
dilution series from different Mach
communities would be would be nice to
help make more quantitative distinctions
in that area alright finally I want to
thank all the people who have supported
me in developing and executing
and persisting to the end of my thesis
project especially Lisa Karstens my
advisor the rest of my Advisory
Committee mark as cliff Guangming whoo
and she will song thank you all very
much for being on my team also my family
some of whom are here my girlfriend for
putting up with my antisocial behavior
for the last year or more and Shannon
McWeeny
for for helping with the early
development of my ideas and all of you
for being here so thanks and if you have
questions or critique Saur anything you
want to comment I like that I think we
have some time left to take it hopefully
[Applause]
thank you um thanks a lot vincent very
nice to talk um just one critique i had
is one i've mentioned before is that
your benchmark if you like is number of
sequences as now so presumably two
sequences could come from the same bug
right the same species bacteria so from
a biological standpoint do your 100 say
contaminant sequences come from ten
bacteria do they come from a hundred
different bacteria which is pretty
important right when we think about the
ecosystem is that yeah and I guess I
think that it depends on what the goal
of your experiment is because sometimes
if only broad distinctions are important
I mean that's certainly that certainly
the extension into the biological realm
and it's a valid point I think sometimes
the differences are only important at a
broad level and then you know a lot of
the sequences that that that I'm showing
these message detecting might be grouped
into many fewer but also I've read
benchmarking studies that are suggesting
that organisms that are of the same
species
but have a very small difference in
their 16s sequences so that they are
purportedly from different strains
actually occupy distinct ecological
niches and so if that's something that's
important to your research then I think
that even the very fine sequence
differences my
matter okay one more question when I
have the mic so it seems that deep blur
and data to probably the best algorithms
that you test it more or less you know
and I wonder if you could comment on the
ease of implementation of these two
different algorithms like we're cheating
would be is that one is clearly much
easier than another
since you've implemented both I think
the most obvious difference between them
in terms of use is that D blur is quite
a bit faster to run then data too
because if you remember data to users it
estimates its error model from the data
and that estimation step takes a long
time in the algorithm and the blur uses
a model that's specified beforehand so
if you have limited computing resources
then deployer might be your friend also
D blur has more of a I don't wanna be
derogatory but it was a canned pipeline
where you can call one command and it
sort of runs the whole thing whereas
data 2 is implemented in R and you have
to use several commands in an R script
to properly execute the data to pipeline
so I say do blur is a little bit easier
and faster
Eric okay
awesome talk I really enjoyed it um
curious about the contaminants that you
found um did you investigate what those
were
by any chance I did a little bit that
might be interesting yeah I would have
liked to do more digging into
distinguishing what was there yeah um
mostly what I saw is that the vast
majority of them are bacterial or
prokaryotic but it's almost surprisingly
there were a handful that hit the NT
reference that were not prokaryotic
remember a bunch of a bunch of the
matching various species of Camellia but
but they were at very low abundance and
and I looked at those sequences and they
believe they barely showed up but I
think it's even possible that you know
in a lab that you know it's close to a
flower bed outside if something could
sneak in there who knows but no I I'd
like to look more into that and that
would be a way to take this project
further and look at what what those
contaminants really are and how conflict
we might be that they are biological
kind of dovetails on that question but I
get asked all the time in a different
context about something about cancer can
play so contamination in terms of
influencing inference of somatic
mutations I'm just thinking in terms of
guidelines like you did a very nice job
of the algorithms in terms of
sensitivity and specificity and aim one
but one of the questions is for a lot of
people they're not going to know how
contaminated their data sets are so do
you feel comfortable kind of with a
thought for the community in the
microbiome you know the microbiome
community about that or you uncover like
it just it's just a question you know
and I'll give you a preface that in the
cancer community we know that the level
of contamination will vary patient the
patient so I'm not the point I'm just
curious your thoughts after doing all
this about that so if a very patient
patient maybe it has something do it
with sample collection oh it absolutely
does I'm just thinking for micro making
that analogy so I'm just curious for
your thoughts with the microbiome work
you know so in a real sample it would be
you couldn't apply the classification
that I scheme that I use to a sample
that wasn't a mock community because you
wouldn't have any idea what the
reference is work I was thinking more
about the methods like the gut you know
some of these questions where people are
saying you know you're showing that the
inference methods are sensitive to level
of contamination and so I was just
thinking as a guideline to the community
given that you know I'm out there doing
work in this area I'm trying to leverage
the things that you're doing I'm just
wondering if you feel comfortable but
you don't have to making a statement
about that in terms of what you might
because we're often asked this what
method should I use and so I'm just
curious your thoughts doing all this
work well I think I would still feel
much more confident using an error model
method for for inference of anything
really
I think otu methods are you know
probably on their way out and more
sophisticated algorithms have been
developed in the error model methods and
their results show that but I don't
think that using those methods on their
own without some further development of
an algorithm to identify the contaminant
which is sort of suggesting at the end
there those methods on their own are not
going to tell you how contaminated your
sample is we need more research into
identifying something like like a trend
or a dilution series for example from
the data that I've looked at it looks
like that trend shows up a lot in those
contaminating sequences so I think that
there's a way of I think there's a
formula you can come up with that would
give you a pretty good sense but but
that's that's further research that I'm
pretty interested in and looking at
maybe we will we will
so for the airmall methods one approach
is to use a private model that's already
predetermined the other ones estimate
the word models estimate estimated from
the data I wonder
knowing using this mock community and
knowing at least the premiere footage
rather the references if not the whole
ground truth could that knowledge help
you in return to estimate to have a
better estimate of their model for the
purchase after using them the non prior
approach like the data to that you let
estimates from the data so if I
understand your question right I think
with another extension of this that I
would like to do is looking at mock
communities that have different error
profiles if you look at the the output
of the sequencer error it tells you the
sequencer will tell you its confidence
in the quality of its data and so if I
use that quality information and I have
data sets with different qualities I'd
like to do a study that should that um
that looks at them the methods
performance across different quality
profiles and see how if there's wild
variation with quality or if it stays
pretty consistent my guess is that Donna
too would do better in that scenario
because it does look at the data and use
that quality information and estimating
its model and I think that that was even
somewhat apparent I didn't want to point
it out because it was kind of a side
point but there was
yeah so here there's I think there's
there tends to be much more variation
between methods on the Zemo and Kozik
datasets in the number of sequences
inferred and one thing I didn't mention
is that these datasets do have lower
quality profiles than these two over
here and I think that helps explain this
this lighter variation but yeah and you
do see it in the in the in the models
although it doesn't look like data to is
doing better I think there's another
reason for that but that's kind of
getting into the weeds sorry Vince
questions one more um I just wanted to
do you know for those four different our
mock communities were similar DNA
extraction protocol is used for them and
then second part of that question did
you see any overlap in terms of
sequences that might be common lab
contaminants that he might say find in
four different labs maybe because
they're using the same construction kit
or whatever I don't know
I start my head with the extraction kids
were for the floor so I can't comment on
whether they were the same or not I can
say that I was shocked by the the the
level of quality by in the sequencing
data from sure Miranda Maudie it looked
like it was really really really good
and I've seen now a lot of alumina
sequencing runs and I rarely see that
profile so it's possible that it was
filtered before it was published but I
don't even think that's the answer
um so I wasn't such a good question oh
right so I did I did classify sequences
that showed up in all the data sets but
then I didn't summarize it for the talk
and so I there certainly are some but
but out of you know there was over 300
contaminants detected at certain
Aleutians and so certainly there's some
of them that show up and all the data
sets but I'm not sure if that's
meaningful particularly but I'd be happy
to look at it more for you later um this
is a comment following up on that
actually would be quite interesting
though if you're actually sister for the
publication because we actually can
learn a lot from that if it
certain ones that they keep coming up
and all the method to do well or some
method to do different so that
additional piece can actually really
valuable in the community yeah and I
guess my assumption also is that that's
going to tend to be a batch effect
depending on the lab where they were
processed quickly could be but you won't
know until you yeah and other papers
have taken that approach of just trying
to catalog common contaminants but I
don't think it's been gone across enough
study centers or labs for that to be a
confident database okay so we firstly
need to cut off questions for time so um
for friends and family who would like to
wait for Vincent we can ask you to wait
out in the hall because we need to clear
the room the committee is going to have
a closed session with him so thank you
very much and if you join me one more
time in thanking him for it